[Music]
Donald Trump as I said he continues to
cause problems for the Republican Party
because of his controversial viewpoints
companies like coca-cola BuzzFeed and
Microsoft have all announced they will
not run advertising on the Republican
National Party's website or during its
convention this summer they're not going
to do it now
luckily for Donald's some other
companies have stepped in to fill the
void for example there's Nabisco's all
white Oreo cookies there's Diaz's
prepaid by Mexico walls yeah yeah those
are snap together quickly there's King
comfort tiny gloves yeah
there's wife builder net trade your old
model for a supermodel in 15 minutes or
less
there's ban Muslims antiperspirant and
believe me it's butter I know butter
and finally Air Canada they're gonna do
really well
[Applause]
you